the Bishops really have become in some
ways The Unofficial opposition to the
government in the upper house now
there's two ways to look at this I think
Robert's case and the way he makes this
argument is that effectively the
leadership of the Church of England has
moved to the left since the 1960s less L
people going to the church but
conversely the liberal Roots enact upon
by the leadership of the Church of
England has only gone one way and that's
continuing in that direction the other
way to look at it of course is that
increasingly the conservative party and
the government have little truck with
the church of England leadership Asel
brav and the Home Secretary had
repeatedly refused to meet just in wellp
to discuss the small boats crisis so I
think really it shows the two
institutions of the state coming apart
the Tory party is less interested in
what the church is saying the Church of
England is increasingly very vocal about
attacking the government